je savais pas qu'on pouvait encore voter
en prison
c'est juste que je viens d'apprendre
très récemment il ya même pas dix jours
[Musique]
je trouve que ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
bien parce que si c'était des matches
nuls il aurait pas eu de charme de répit
le même mouvement que à l'extérieur
alors nous font ressentir comme si vous
venez à l'extérieur sens et à
l'extérieur et c'est bien
de plus en plus suspect pour voter
de mémoire on avait commencé en 2019
avec les élections européennes on avait
60 soixantaine de détenus qui voulaient
voter
là on emmenait à 133 qui sont inscrits
sur la liste électorale certes élections
européennes élection présidentielle la
participation n'est pas là même aux deux
élections mais on voit quand même que
les
de plus en plus de l'élite ne
s'intéresse pas aux élections
[Musique]